BOSTON.
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE.
>> Steve:: READ BY ZACHA.E OUT P
OF THE CREASE.
FIGHT IT OFF.
JUST GOT A
>> Ken: DEVILS HAVE T T
IN
SURE.
HERE IS HOLTZ IN TRANSITION.
GETS TO
THE BRUINS TAKE  ON THE RBACK.
BRAD MARCHAND WATCHED BY
HISCHIER.
MARCHAND IN CLOSED
DOWN BY VESEY.
THERE.
YOU SEE BERGERON ONLY WAY THEY
WILL BEAT SWAYMAN HERE THIS
AFTERNOOOO
MARCHAND PLAYS IT ACROSS
PASTRNAK'S SHOT.
NOBODY 3-1 GAME. ZACHA.
DOES WELL TO CONTROL.
DEVILS PICK UP PASS.
THAT STARTED IN THE DEVILS
ANOTHER WHACK AT IT ON A SECOND
IT A 3-2 GAME!
AROUND.
ONE MORSUBBAN IS BLOCKED.
BRUINS COULD USE A CHANGE HERE.
MERCER CUTS COME IT ACROS
>> Ken: THEY HAVE COME OUT WITH
THEIR LEGS IN THE DEFINITIVELY.
>> Ken: WELL, YEAH.IVE.
LOOKED LIKE THE REF MIGHT HAVE
LOST SIGHT OF THE PUCK.
ONE MORE LOOK FROM BETTER ANGLE.
JOHNSSON TO CENTER.
PLAYS IT ACROSS.
BRATT FOR DAWSON
>> Ken: HE CUTS TO TH OUT.
DeBRUSK LOOKS AT THE
BRAD AND